Today we're learning English with Disney-Pixar's
animation Brave. You'll learn about Scottish
English pronunciation and also lots of
vocabulary that you can start using right now.
In case you're new here the scenes
we've chosen have no spoilers
you'll watch two scenes from the movie, learn
the vocabulary and then have the chance to watch
it again without the subtitles. Because here we
help you learn English with your favorite movies
and series without getting lost, without missing
the jokes and without subtitles just like Drew
who says that ours is the best English channel
ever! So make sure you join our community by
hitting the subscribe button and the bell down
below, that way you'll never miss a new lesson!
So here at Learn English with TV Series
we are celebrating the fact that we just
reached 4 million subscribers! And to thank you
for all of your support and to help you continue
making learning English both fun and effective
we have a special present just for you. We've
recently started offering an amazing 50% discount
to 900 of you who want to become Fluent over the
next 10 months with our popular Fluency course
Fluent with Friends. And if you're watching this
lesson today as we publish it you may still have a
chance to get it. Now wouldn't you just love it if
this time next year you could enjoy your favorite
tv series and movies without the subtitles?
Be able to talk to natives naturally and also
understand what they are saying without needing
to ask them to slow down or repeat. So if you
don't want to miss out on this opportunity to
finally achieve your English Fluency click on the
link in the description below. There you'll be
able to learn more about the lessons and join
the course and our community of students now
again there are almost no coupons left for this
promotion so this is probably your last chance to
take advantage of this offer and get the complete
package of Fluent with Friends at 50 percent off.
Just click on the link in the description right
now and make sure to use the coupon code gift
check out to get your exclusive discount.
Now let's get back to the lesson with brave!